I would like to take this opportunity to welcome you to the Faculty of Language Studies.
Before I introduce you to the tutors in this faculty, I want to ask two basic questions.
What is a language?
And what is linguistics?
Firstly, what is a language?
Well, everybody knows that English is a language...
...and that Spanish and Japanese are others in this category.
But we also know that English is not used in the same way in New York as it is in London.
You may also know that English is not used in the same way in London...
...as it is in the north of England, say, or the west of England.
So English is a language, but it has many varieties.
We could say there are many "Englishes" just as there are many "Spanishes."
The intrinsic meaning of language is a shared system of expression particular to a nation or people.
But in fact, one language can have many varieties,...
...for example, British English, American English, Cockney, which is London English,...
...Scouse, which is English spoken by people from Liverpool, and so on.
What is French to a businessman in Paris is not the same French used by an old woman in Lyon.
You can be sure that it will be very different to that of a teenage boy in Quebec.